qu'on interdirait la démocratie si jamais elle menaçait de changer quoi que ce soit.
Ce soir, ici, je veux vous présenter
le cas économique d'une démocratie authentique.
Je veux vous demander, avec moi, de croire à nouveau,
que Lee Kuan Yew,
le Parti communiste chinois
et en effet l'Eurogroupe
se trompent lorsqu'ils pensent qu'on peut se passer de démocratie –
et que nous avons besoin d'une vraie démocratie, avec ce côté turbulent.
Et sans la démocratie,
nos sociétés seront plus mauvaises,
notre futur sombre
et nos géniales nouvelles technologies, bien mal utilisées.
En parlant de gaspillage,
permettez-moi de signaler un paradoxe intéressant
qui menace nos économies en ce moment.
Je l'appelle le paradoxe du double sommet.
Le premier, on comprend –
on sait ce que c'est, on le reconnait –
c'est la montagne de dettes, qui a projeté sa grande ombre
sur les États-Unis, l'Europe, le monde entier.
Nous reconnaissons tous la montagne de dettes.
Mais peu de personnes discernent sa sœur jumelle.
Une montagne d'argent inactif
appartenant aux riches épargnants et aux entreprises,
trop terrifiés pour l'investir
dans des activités productives pouvant générer des revenus
qui permettraient de faire disparaître la montagne de dettes
et qui pourraient produire tout ce dont l'humanité a tant besoin,
comme des énergies vertes.
Maintenant laissez-moi vous donner deux chiffres.
Durant les trois derniers mois,
aux États-Unis, en Grande-Bretagne et dans la zone euro,
nous avons investi, collectivement, 3400 milliards de dollars
dans tous les biens créateurs de richesse –
des choses comme des sites industriels, de l'équipement,
des immeubles de bureaux, des écoles,
des routes, chemins de fer, des machines, et ainsi de suite.
3400 milliards de dollars, ça semble beaucoup d'argent
jusqu'à ce que l'on les compare aux 5100 milliards de dollars
gaspillés dans les mêmes pays,
dans nos institutions financières,
ne servant absolument à rien pendant cette même période
à part faire gonfler la bourse et le prix des maisons.
Donc cette montagne de dettes et cette montagne d'argent inactif
forment des montagnes jumelles, qui devraient s'éliminer mutuellement
si on les remettait dans la boucle normale des marchés.
Résultat : les salaires stagnent,
plus d'un quart des 25-54 ans en Amérique, au Japon et en Europe
est au chômage.
Et donc, la faible demande mondiale,
prise dans une spirale sans fin,
renforce le pessimisme des investisseurs,
qui, craignant la faible demande, la reproduisent en n'investissant pas –
exactement comme le père d'Œdipe,
qui, terrifié par la prophétie de l'oracle
annonçant que son fils le tuerait,
crée involontairement les conditions
amenant Œdipe, son fils, à le tuer.
Voilà en quoi je conteste le capitalisme.
Ce gaspillage indécent,
tout cet argent inactif,
devrait être utilisé pour améliorer nos vies,
développer les talents,
et en effet, pour financer toutes ces technologies,
les technologies vertes,
qui sont absolument essentielles pour sauver la planète.
Ai-je raison de croire que la démocratie peut être la réponse ?
Je veux le croire,
mais avant de continuer,
qu'entend-on par démocratie ?
Aristote définit la démocratie
comme une organisation dans laquelle l'homme libre et le pauvre,
étant la majorité, contrôlent le gouvernement.
Maintenant, la démocratie athénienne excluait bien sûr trop de gens.
Les femmes, les immigrés et, bien sûr, les esclaves.
Mais ce serait une erreur
de nier l'importance de l'ancienne démocratie athénienne
sur la base de qui elle excluait.
Ce qui était plus pertinent,
et qui continue de l'être à propos de l'ancienne démocratie athénienne,
était l'intégration des travailleurs pauvres,
qui avaient non seulement acquis le droit de s'exprimer librement,
mais aussi celui plus important et crucial
d'émettre des jugements politiques
qui leur conférait le même poids
dans les prises de décision concernant les problèmes d'État.
Bien sûr, la démocratie athénienne n'a pas duré dans le temps.
Comme une bougie brillant de mille feux, elle a brûlé trop rapidement.
Et en fait,
nos démocraties libérales ne descendent pas de l'Athènes antique.
Leurs racines puisent dans la Magna Carta,
dans la Glorieuse Révolution de 1688,
et sans doute dans la constitution américaine.
Là où la démocratie athénienne était centrée sur le citoyen sans maître
et donnait du pouvoir au travailleur pauvre,
nos démocraties libérales sont fondées sur la tradition de la Magna Carta,
qui était, après tout, une charte pour les maîtres.
Et en fait, la démocratie libérale n'apparut que lorsqu'il fut possible
de bien séparer la sphère politique de la sphère économique,
pour confiner le processus démocratique entièrement dans la sphère politique,
laissant la sphère économique –
le monde des affaires, si vous voulez –
comme une zone non-démocratique.
Maintenant, aujourd'hui dans nos démocraties,
cette séparation de l'économie de la sphère politique,
dès qu'elle a commencé à se produire,
a initié une inexorable et épique bataille entre les deux,
la sphère économique colonisant la sphère politique,
dévorant son pouvoir.
Vous êtes vous demandé pourquoi les politiciens ont changé ?
Ce n'est pas leur ADN qui a dégénéré.
(Rires)
Mais plutôt parce qu'on peut aujourd'hui gouverner sans avoir le pouvoir,
car le pouvoir a migré de la sphère politique à l'économique,
qui est à part.
Et donc,
je parlais de mon problème avec le capitalisme.
Quand on y pense,
c'est un peu comme une population de prédateurs,
qui sont si talentueux pour décimer les proies dont ils se nourrissent
qu'à la fin, ils n'ont plus rien à manger.
De façon similaire,
la sphère économique a colonisé et dévoré la sphère politique
à tel point qu'elle se sape elle-même,
causant des crises économiques.
Le pouvoir des entreprises augmente,
les biens politiques dévalorisés,
les inégalités augmentent,
la demande globale s'écroule
et les chefs d'entreprises ont trop peur d'investir l'argent de leurs entreprises.
Donc plus le capitalisme retire le pouvoir au peuple,
plus hautes sont les montagnes jumelles,
plus on gaspille les ressources humaines
et la richesse de l'humanité.
De toute évidence, si cela est juste,
il faut que nous réunissions les sphères politique et économique
et autant le faire sous le contrôle du peuple
comme dans l'ancienne Athènes, mais sans esclaves
ou exclusion des femmes et des migrants.
Ce n'est pas une idée originale.
La gauche marxiste a eu cette idée il y a 100 ans
et ça n'a pas bien marché, non ?
La leçon que nous avons apprise de la débâcle soviétique
est qu'il faudrait un miracle pour rendre le pouvoir aux travailleurs pauvres
comme ils l'étaient dans l'ancienne Athènes,
sans créer de nouvelles formes de brutalité et de gaspillages.
Mais il y a une solution :
éliminer les travailleurs pauvres.
Le capitalisme le fait en remplaçant
les emplois peu rémunérés par des automates, androïdes, ou robots.
Le problème est que tant
que les sphères politique et économique sont séparées,
l'automatisation ne fera qu'alimenter les montagnes jumelles,
augmenter le gaspillage
et approfondir les conflits sociaux,
y compris –
et bientôt, je crois –
dans des endroits comme la Chine.
Donc il nous faut réaménager,
il faut que nous réunissions les sphères économique et politique,
et nous avons tout intérêt à le faire en démocratisant les sphères réunifiées,
ou on se retrouvera sous un régime hyper-autocratique, fou de surveillance,
qui donnera à Matrix, le film, un air de documentaire.
(Rires)
Mais la question n'est pas de savoir si le capitalisme survivra
aux innovations technologiques qu'il a vu naître.
Il est plus intéressant de se demander
si ce qui succédera au capitalisme s'approchera d'une dystopie comme Matrix
ou de quelque chose de plus proche de la société de Star Trek,
où les machines servent les humains
et les humains consacrent leur énergie à l'exploration de l'univers
et au plaisir d'échanger longuement sur le sens de la vie
dans des agoras high-tech, aux airs athéniens et antiques.
Je pense que nous pouvons nous permettre d'être optimistes.
Mais que faudrait-il,
comment cela serait-ce
si nous vivions l'utopie de Star Trek plutôt que la dystopie de Matrix ?
Sur le plan pratique,
permettez-moi juste de partager brièvement,
quelques exemples.
Au niveau des entreprises,
imaginez un marché financier,
où vous gagnez du capital en travaillant,
et où votre capital vous suit d'un travail à un autre,
d'une compagnie à une autre,
et la compagnie –
celle où vous travaillez à ce moment, n'importe laquelle –
est entièrement détenue par ceux qui y travaillent à ce moment.
Alors tous les revenus découleront du capital, des profits,
et le concept même du salaire salarié deviendra obsolète.
Plus de clivage entre ceux qui possèdent sans travailler dans l'entreprise
et ceux qui travaillent mais ne possèdent pas la compagnie ;
plus de lutte acharnée entre capital et travail ;
plus de grand écart entre l'investissement et l'épargne ;
en de fait, plus de montagnes jumelles immenses.
Au niveau de la politique économique mondiale,
imaginez un moment
que nos devises nationales aient un taux d'échange à flottement libre,
avec une devise digitale, universelle, mondiale,
issue par le Fonds Monétaire International,
le G-20,
au nom de toute l'humanité.
Et imaginez ensuite
que tous les échanges internationaux se fassent dans cette devise –
appelons-la « le cosmos »,
en unités de cosmos –
et que chaque gouvernement accepte de placer dans un fonds commun
une somme d'unités cosmos proportionnelle au déficit commercial du pays,
ou a contrario à l'excédent commercial du pays.
Et imaginez qu'on investisse ce fonds dans des technologies vertes,
surtout dans des parties du monde où les investissements manquent.
Cette idée n'est pas nouvelle.
C'est en réalité ce que John Maynard Keynes a proposé
en 1944 à la conférence de Bretton Woods.
Le problème est
qu'à l'époque, ils n'avaient pas la technologie pour l'implémenter.
Maintenant nous l'avons,
surtout dans le contexte d'une sphère politico-économique réunifiée.
Le monde que je vous décris
est tout à la fois libertaire,
car il donne la priorité au pouvoir individuel,
Marxiste,
puis qu'il veut enfermer dans les poubelles de l'histoire
la division entre capital et travail,
et Keynésien,
Keynésien à l'échelle mondiale.
Mais par-dessus tout,
c'est un monde qui nous permettra d'imaginer une démocratie authentique.
Un tel monde peut-il naître ?
Ou devrons-nous tomber dans une dystopie à la Matrix ?
La réponse dépend du choix politique que nous devons faire collectivement.
C'est notre choix,
et il vaudrait mieux le faire démocratiquement.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)
Bruno Giussani : Yanis...
Tu te décrivais toi-même comme un marxiste libertaire dans ta bio.
Quelle est la pertinence de l'analyse de Marx aujourd'hui ?
Yanis Varoufakis : Eh bien, si on juge ce que je viens de dire pertinent,
alors Marx est pertinent.
Car tout l'intérêt de réunifier la politique et l'économie est –
si nous ne le faisons pas,
alors l'innovation technologique va créer
une telle chute de la demande globale,
ce que Larry Summers appelle une stagnation séculaire.
Et cette crise, en migrant d'une partie à l'autre du monde,
comme actuellement,
déstabilisera non seulement nos démocraties, mais également
ce monde émergent qui n'est pas si enclin à la démocratie libérale.
Donc si cette analyse tient la route, alors Marx est absolument pertinent.
Mais Hayek également,
c'est pourquoi je suis un Marxiste libertaire,
et Keynes aussi,
donc voilà pourquoi je suis si déconcerté.
(Rires)
BG : Tout à fait, et on l'est sans doute aussi, maintenant.
(Applaudissements)
YV : Si on n'est pas déconcerté, c'est qu'on ne réfléchit pas, non ?
BG : Ça fait très, très philosophe grec de dire ça –
YV : C'est d'Einstein, à vrai dire –
BG : Pendant votre discours, vous avez parlé de Singapour et la Chine,
et la nuit dernière au dîner,
vous exprimiez une assez forte opinion sur comment l'Occident juge la Chine.
Pourriez-vous la partager ?
YV : Bon, il y a un grand degré d'hypocrisie.
Dans nos démocraties libérales, nous avons un semblant de démocratie.
Ceci car nous avons réduit, comme je disais plus tôt,
la démocratie à la sphère politique,
tout en laissant la sphère où précisément se passe toute l'action –
la sphère économique –
être une zone non-démocratique.
Dans un sens,
si je peux me permettre cette provocation,
la Chine aujourd'hui est plus proche de la Grande-Bretagne du 19ème siècle.
Parce que souvenez-vous,
on associe souvent libéralisme et démocratie –
mais c'est faux, historiquement.
Libéralisme, libéral, c'est comme John Stuart Mill.
John Stuart Mill était particulièrement sceptique quant au processus démocratique.
Et ce qu'on voit maintenant en Chine est un processus très similaire
à celui qu'il y a eu en Grande-Bretagne pendant la Révolution Industrielle,
particulièrement la transition de la première à la seconde.
Et reprocher à la Chine
de faire ce que l'Occident a fait au 19ème siècle,
a des relents d'hypocrisie.
BG : Je suis sûr que beaucoup se posent des questions à propos de votre expérience
comme Ministre des Finances grec, plus tôt cette année.
YV : Je savais que ça viendrait.
BG : Oui.
BG : Six mois après,
quel bilan tirez-vous de la première moitié de l'année ?
YV : Extrêmement excitant, d'un point de vue personnel,
et très décevant,
car nous avions une opportunité de réinitialiser la zone euro.
Pas seulement la Grèce, la zone euro.
Pour en finir avec la complaisance
et le déni constant qu'il y avait une énorme –
qu'il y a énorme ligne de faille
dans la zone euro,
qui menace, massivement, le processus entier de l'Union Européenne.
Nous avions une opportunité basée sur le programme grec –
qui d'ailleurs,
était le premier programme à manifester ce déni –
et le rectifier.
Et, malheureusement,
les pouvoirs de la zone euro,
de l'Eurogroupe,
ont choisi de maintenir ce déni.
Mais vous savez ce qui se passe.
C'est l'expérience de l'Union Soviétique.
Quand on essaie de garder en vie
un système économique voué architecturalement à l'échec,
grâce au pouvoir politique et à l'autoritarisme,
vous pouvez réussir à le prolonger,
mais quand le changement arrive,
il arrive de façon très brusque et catastrophique.
BG : Quel type de changement prévoyez-vous ?
YV : Eh bien, sans aucun doute,
si l'architecture de la zone euro n'est pas changée,
la zone euro n'a pas d'avenir.
BG : Avez-vous fait des erreurs en tant que Ministre ?
YV : Tous les jours. BG : Par exemple ?
YV : Quiconque regarde en arrière –
(Applaudissements)
Non, mais sérieusement.
Si n'importe quel Ministres des Finances, ou d'autre chose
vous dit après six mois à son poste,
particulièrement dans une situation si stressante,
qu'il n'a pas fait d'erreurs, alors c'est une personne dangereuse.
Bien sûr que je me suis trompé.
Ma plus grande erreur a été de signer l'application
pour l'extension des accords de prêt,
fin février.
J'imaginais qu'il y avait un intérêt véritable
pour les créditeurs
à trouver un terrain d'entente.
Mais il n'y en avait pas.
Ils voulaient juste écraser notre gouvernement,
parce qu'ils ne voulaient pas
avoir à s'occuper de la ligne de faille
qui fracture la zone euro.
Et parce qu'ils n'ont pas voulu admettre
que pendant cinq ans ils appliquaient un programme catastrophique en Grèce.
Nous avons perdu un tiers de notre PIB.
Ce qui est pire que pendant la Grande Dépression.
Et personne,
dans la troïka des prêteurs imposant ce programme
n'a admis que c'était une erreur colossale.
BG : En dépit de tout ça,
et en dépit de la véhémence de la discussion,
vous semblez rester assez pro-Européen.
YV : Absolument.
Vous voyez, la critique que j'émets sur l'Union Européenne et la zone euro
vient d'une personne qui ne vit que pour l'Europe.
Ma plus grande peur est que la zone euro ne survive pas.
Et si elle ne survit pas,
les forces centrifuges qui seront libérées
seront monstrueuses,
et détruiront l'Union Européenne.
Et ce sera catastrophique pas seulement pour l'Europe
mais pour toute l'économie.
Nous sommes probablement la plus grande économie dans le monde.
Et si nous nous laissons
retomber dans les pas des années 30 postmodernes,
ce qui me semble être le cas,
alors cela nuira
à l'avenir des Européens mais aussi des non-Européens.
BG : Nous espérons bien sûr que vous avez tort sur ce point.
Yanis, merci d'être venu à TED.
YV : Merci.
(Applaudissements)